Guten morgen time.
Es wird nicht mehr lange dauern dann liegst du im graben lieber tim.
Logbuch politik drei zwo eins feuer feuer feuer feuer feuer.
Da ist die dreihundert einundzwanzigste sendung für euch auf den tisch gekippt und ich bin auch wieder zurück von meinen reisen,
so dass wir hier wieder mal gemeinsam am tisch sitzen können ja ich kann schon mal fünfer rauslegen ja.
Sauber bügeln bitte.
Soweit ist es noch nicht.
Du hast auch wieder brexit podcasts net.
Genau es war mal wieder zeit für ein update das gibt's auf k w punkt fm,
die sechste folge es wieder mit schon was und wer mal zusammen gefegt was so in den letzten drei monaten alles so passiert ist das war so einiges,
und na ja was jetzt so ansteht mit den neuwahlen ende des jahres und wieder die chancen so stehen und jetzt wird's nochmal spannend.
Dass die sich nicht schämen.
Oder schämen sich eine ganze menge leute das kannst du also ich würde sagen so mal alle leute die irgendwie nicht komplett hören amputiert sind die schämen sie schon wirklich enorm das das ist ein wirklich wirklich wirklich peinlich.
Was soll das denn wirklich wirklich es ist wirklich peinlich.
Da würden wir uns in derselben situation auch entsprechend schämen.
Ja wer es ist ja nicht so als hätten wir in deutschland nichts zu schämen.
Ne das ist in der tat war und wo könnte man das besser immer wieder feststellen als bundespolitik.
Ja
Euer schämen kanal.
Okay dann fang ich mal an mit dem feedback zur letzten sendung.
Da gab's so einiges du hast dich ja unterhalten mit wie ist die dame noch gleich stefan.
Elke steven von digitale gesellschaft und da fiel mir feedback uns sebastian.
Mit einigen
korrekturen es ist nicht korrekt das mit dem digitale versorgungs- gesetz und forschungs- daten zentrum erstmals ein solcher dienst entsteht ein solcher daten polieren stünde der daten pool besteht bereits seit längerer zeit,
das das thema ist also nicht wirklich neu es geht eher darum dass diese jetzt eben anders.
Geteilt werden stand jetzt werden zum zwecke des sogenannten mobilität orientierten risiko risiko struktur ausgleich,
also der der mobilität ist ja die ja die wahrscheinlich.
Sterblichkeit orientierte risiko struktur ausgleich,
das heißt der der bedeutet die berechnung der zuweisen,
der zuweisungen die die krankenkassen für ihre versicherten aus dem gesundheitsvorsorge erhalten die richten sich quasi nach dem zu erwartenden mobilität von.
So stand jetzt werden die zum zwecke der sogenannten mobilität orientierten risiko struktur ausgleichs von allen kassen die in rede stehenden abrechnung starten,
also sozialer verschreiben jährlich solidarisiert an das bundesvorsitz gesamt übermittelt das führt die daten zur berechnung des.
A risiko struktur gleich natürlich zusammen zudem werden die daten auch jetzt schon zur forschungszentrum an das,
der deutsche äh was ist denn die jetzt hab ich gerade nicht mehr im kopf.
Wer hat sowas schon im kopf das ist das deutsche institut für medizinische dokumentation und informationen was nicht alles gibt.
Neu war im bisherigen entwurf dass die daten und direkt an den,
k v sv übermittelt werden und zwar ohne pseudo anonymisierung ansonsten existiert die daten meldung an sich auch jetzt schon gesundheitsausschuss.
Hat heute ja zudem,
pseudonym visierung gestanden also das ist die anmerkung heute meint er wahrscheinlich gerade das datum nicht den tag an dem das entschieden wurde dieses gesetz über das wir in der letzten sendung gesponnen neu ist zudem die einrichtung eines
explizit sogenannten forschungs- daten zentrums bisher gab es die daten zu forschung zwecken aber unter bestimmten und umständen auch schon beim dem die das heißt.
Er sagt so viel ändert sich da nicht außer oder beziehungsweise vieles von dem was ich da jetzt ändert gibt es in.
Ähnlicher form ohnehin schon.
Und dann haben wir ein relativ langes feedback bekommen was ich was wir jetzt mal anonymisiert haben weil es so interessant ist.
Und tim gibt sich jetzt mühe ja ich hoffe wir haben alle persönlich identifiziert waren informationen entfernt.
Bestimmt aus dem metadaten kann man bestimmt nichts gewinnen ich könnte zufällig,
im grunde ein nutznießer dieses gesetzes und der folgenden eben zum beispiel das digitale vorsorge gesetzes von der idee her sein,
denn eine idee hinter dem gesetz und im folgenden ist meditationen der patienten zu hinterlegen.
Oder das wäre dann bereits die möglichkeit die bisher so konkret noch nicht benannt wurde interdisziplinäre diagnosen gegebenenfalls zusammenziehen zu können.
Also mein beispiel ich wurde vor etwa vier jahren wegen eines sogenannten akustik.
Ja ist das akustik us neu genommen s klingt.
Klingt gefährlich mehr oder weniger not operiert symptome sind meistens,
der verlust gesichts lähmung manchmal schwindel,
manchmal neues tag muss was man das sein mag mit einem tinnitus geht man vielleicht zum arzt und mit einem hörverlust auch du musst ein tinnitus nicht mit einem,
und ich zum beispiel habe mein hörverlust unter dem tinnitus gar nicht bemerkt ist also nie.
Schlag muss ist wenn deine augen sich auf einmal unkontrolliert bewegen.
Ah ja mit einer.
Das ist die gesichts lähmung geht man aber eher zum neurologen wenn man sie denn bemerkt,
ein tag mus bemerkt man bis zu einem gewissen grad vielleicht gar nicht da diese gut artigen tumore in der regel sehr langsam wachsen in meinem fall circa,
fünfhundert zentimetern geschätzt zwölf bis fünfzehn jahren treten diese symptome sehr langsam auf daher bemerkt man sie vielleicht gar nicht,
wenn eine gewisse größe erreicht ist können die riegel abgedrückt werden was den hirn druck erhöht und zu massiven kopfschmerzen führt hier sind wir im lebensbedrohlichen bereich.
Dieser tumor relativ selten ist und in der notaufnahme oft junge,
und ihr unerfahrene ärzte arbeiten kann es sein dass selbst sie als ärzte diese symptome nicht in einen zusammenhang bringen können wenn jemand über massive kopfschmerzen klagt und oben genante symptome aufweist.
Erst ein etwas erfahrener neurologe oder in absprache mit einem neurochirurg wird ein fall eines der großen.
Das zieht sich jetzt auf den.
Akustik.
Neu genommen genau kürzung in erwägung ziehen und ebenfalls ein veranlassen und das wird dann gefunden also man sieht resonanz therapie diese.
Tomographie diese maschine die man dann manchmal reingeschoben wird wenn nur da man ist.
Die also die bild ein bild geben das verfahren dass dreidimensional die strukturen abbilden kann also cd beziehungsweise eigentlich,
visualisiert das dichte.
Genau da ist noch so ein bisschen prinzip die besten beste methode den körper quasi von innen an.
Die coolsten bilder.
Ohne ohne ihn anzuschneiden mit der vernetzung der verschiedenen ärzte wäre es nun möglich die symptome zusammen zu ziehen und den ausschluss,
oder sie oder die sicherstellung des verdachts des zu veranlassen,
wenn also der hahn oasien marker tinnitus und hörverlust setzt und ein neurologe den marker gesichts lähmung und des tag muss könnten irgendwo eine warnung auf ein eventuelle akustik erscheinen an sicher keine schlechte idee,
warum sollte ich dagegen sein ich glaube das ist so ein bisschen in der sendung auch.
Vielleicht noch ein bisschen zu kurz gekommen was so für nutzung gerade aus dieser ganzen digitalen vernetzung zu erwarten sind ja ja ja den.
Schwerpunkt auf datenschutz er schreibt weiter nun das gesetz.
Und auch wenn ich gerne auf jens spahn rum hacke das stammt noch von seinem vorgänger hermann gröhe,
sieht also vor allem beteiligten ärzte und oder praxen k v krankenhäuser über die telekommunikationsstruktur zu vernetzen,
das ist natürlich keine kann entscheidung das ist pflicht die ärzte sind per honorar kürzung und zurzeit ein prozent im anschluss an die gezwungen,
die kürzung soll ab märz zwanzig zwanzig zwei komma fünf prozent betragen,
patienten werden natürlich nicht nach ihrer zustimmung gefragt also sieht man wird sozusagen über das geld gezwungen daran teilzunehmen,
die beteiligten haben einen sogenannten connector rum zu stehen über den sie in die tee also telekommunikationsstruktur reingehen,
bereits hier fängt der fehler an diese kollektoren sind ja im grunde einfach lauter diese gründen zumindest stand november achtzehn nur von einem einzigen anbieter geliefert werden.
Zudem sind dort quasi hardware zertifikate verbaut in etwa fünf jahren auslaufen angeblich sind da wenigstens militärische sicherheitsstandards berücksichtigt worden also zumindest bei der ausgabe der konnektoren,
was so router sonst noch für probleme mit sich bringt da seid ihr ja ja die experten das wird dann immer lustig wenn also zertifikate ablaufen und keiner weiß,
das überhaupt welche drin sind.
Also ist der einstieg schon mal maximal verkackt aber natürlich hört das ja da nicht auf im grunde ist die dann ein vw da gibt es mittlerweile,
die thematik bietet auch ein portal an auf dem man sich so zulassung angucken kann sieht noch mehr aus aber da werden die gleichen firmen oft mehrfach benannt auch hinsichtlich v n seid ihr in der lage mögliche probleme aufzuzeigen und am ende sollen die daten dann,
zentral gespeichert werden,
also auch eine denkbar schlechte idee das sind die gesundheitsdaten von dreiundsiebzig millionen gesetzlich versicherten diese speicherung wird in den nächsten jahren zunächst einmal die firma erwartung übernehmen.
Erwarten betreibt daneben noch ein story ging dienst und ein joint venture mit der post identitätsfeststellung oder in deren sprich adresse management.
Man kann sich nur den aluhut aufsetzen und überlegen eine firma weiß einerseits dass du ein hirntumor hast zum anderen entscheidet sie mit ob du einen kredit bekommst.
Den quatsch mit dem verschreiben von apps haben linus und elke bereits etwas beleuchtet und zu den ab selbst ist ja von martin zieht sich alles wissenswerte gesagt.
Tja da habe ich gesagt.
Falsch genau für sich genau vielleicht abgesehen davon das smartphones in der kette vielleicht auch an sich die wahrscheinlich unsichersten stellen sind,
na ja und warum ist das angesichts einer cd dsgvo eigentlich alles überhaupt möglich.
Weil nach artikel sechs nationales recht das leider erforderlich und damit zulässig macht an der stelle sei auf jan philipp albrecht beitrag zu zweihundertsechsundfünfzig verwiesen,
der erzählt hat wie viel da vor allem von den konservativen im europaparlament noch so reingeschrieben worden ist ja.
Wir lassen das jetzt mal weitgehend zu stehen grundsätzlich.
Ich habe ja meine sendung gemacht im forscher geist podcast,
der digitalisierung der medizin und sehr toller toller gesprächspartner,
und naja da muss ich sagen da hab ich dann doch auch noch einen anderen eindruck erhalten der,
wunsch nach einer geordneten digitalisierung in der medizin,
unter anderem solchen sachen die dem verschreiben von apps der ist da sehr stark weil die einfach 'ne hohe medizinische begründung dafür sehen also gerade bei apps ist es so es gibt einfach einzelne behandlung bereiche wo es sehr viel sinn macht,
leute in so.
Überwachte rhythmen reinzubringen oder auch neurotisches durchzuführen et cetera das wenn er einige beispiele genannt und es gibt ja dann auch.
So umstrittene apps wie
das ah da zum beispiel neulich ja auch wieder erwähnung gefunden hat weil sie mit ihrem datenschutz teile verkackt haben was war das irgendwie facebook übermittlung et cetera das darf natürlich
passieren klar aber grundsätzlich sind natürlich auch solche diagnose ab ganz interessant mal die halt auch mit,
maschinen learning und so weiter versuchen im prinzip genau diese,
assoziationen ketten herbeizuführen die hier unser anonymer schreiber,
ja auch sozusagen als sinnvoll erachtet also man hat verschiedene symptome einzelne ärzte sind nicht in der lage das,
zusammen zu rechnen weil sie nicht einfach alle alle nicht die passende formel haben oder eben nicht,
alle parameter sehen sodass eben komplexe krankheitsbilder so nicht erkannt werden kann,
da ist natürlich eine zusammenführung der daten sinnvoll ob das jetzt zwangsläufig zu einer zentralen speicherung führen muss,
das ist eine ganz andere debatte ja also ich denke man kann sich durchaus architekturen vorstellen wo so eine zentrale speicherung von allem über alle nicht unbedingt erforderlich ist man trotzdem diesen benefit haben kann.
Also diesen benefit das finde ich genau den punkt ich bin ja selber nutzer sagen wir mal bestimmter die gesundheit
oder fitness oder sonstige körperliche vitalfunktionen betreffende applikationen ja also dass die mir auch freude bereiten oder fortschritte bereiten
da denke ich,
ist wahrscheinlich in der letzten folge zu wenig anerkennung für gekommen dass diese geräte natürlich oder diese applikation diese anwendung durchaus ein nutzen haben was mich halt immer.
In diesem kontexten durchaus etwas ärgert ist also wer.
Wer hat da am ende was von wem wird das welche risiken
wer muss welche risiken in kauf nehmen und wer macht damit die milliarden ja und das erscheint mir dann doch leider in in vielen dieser anwendungen problematisch,
nur am rande sei hier mal erwähnt um umso das ausmaß diese dieses problem ist nur kurz an zu deuten ich habe zweitausenddreizehn,
oder zweitausendzwölf gab es einen crowdfunding für eine smartwatch people ja relativ simple
in der heutigen maßstab relativ simple smartwatch nach damaligen aber total genial irgendwie eine sms bekommen stand im display konnte es irgendwie einige
funktion damit klären geiles teil ja,
diese,
diese watch hatte natürlich ein dazugehörige ökosystem ja wo man irgendwie apps runterladen konnte und solche scherze,
und war eben über kickstarter finanziert so,
idealisten die gesagt haben er hier dieses gerät kann man bauen wir bauen das.
Drei jahre später wurde people von fitbit gekauft und fitbit hat mehr oder weniger die alten services die alte infrastruktur alles abgeschaltet und ich,
ich bin mir noch nicht mal sicher ob die das nur ein gestampft haben oder eine neue firma auf die uhren geschubst haben weiß ich noch nicht mal ich habe das nicht verfolgt ich habe die uhr dann einfach nicht mehr benutzt ja weil ich kein bock hatte irgendwelche mit einer,
uhr,
alternativ services darum zu rennen das war war für mich in dem moment erledigt gab aber es gibt durchaus auch heute noch eine aktive community die ihre pflegt und lieb weil diese uhr anhaltende,
ich glaube anderthalb wochen akkulaufzeit haben oder so ne die die musste so selten laden das immer der ladekabel nummer suchen muss geile geräte so fitbit wurde jetzt gerade von google gekauft ja,
das heißt,
zwanzig dreizehn wurde mir diese uhr geliefert werde ich dir jetzt immer noch nach sechs jahren am arm hätte hätte ich jetzt halt 'ne google uhr obwohl ich natürlich spezifisch,
die gekauft habe weil da nicht google draufsteht ja und solche entwicklungen.
Da ist es natürlich schön den entgegenzuwirken wenn man,
den nutzerinnen zu beginn solcher digitalisierung halt möglichst viele rechte gibt und zu beginn zu sagen ach übrigens alle daten die wir von euch haben gehen wir jetzt mal weiter.
Das ist schon mal echt ein fatales signal und da da bin ich halt eher ein bisschen unzufrieden mit und ich finde es.
Ich weiß dass der meister der größere teil der menschen auf jeden fall sagt naja ich finde das super ich gebe meine daten hier überall hin und ich profitiere für meine wahrnehmung auch ausreichend davon ist auch in ordnung aber ich würde,
selber gerne diese abwägung nutzen können diese abwägung treffen können natürlich finde ich das cool wenn.
Was weiß ich meine uhr mit e funktion 'ne 'ne schöne schnittstelle hat er sich sowas irgendwann mal eine ärztin,
zur verfügung stellen kann oder die ich weiß nicht wie viele
tausend mal meine uhr jetzt wahrscheinlich mein puls gemessen hat ja zu unterschiedlichen situationen unterschiedliche sportliche leistungen zu unterschiedlichen gewichts zeiten nach hause spannende daten,
die ich gerne einmal analysiert hätte und das kann am ende nur jemand anders für mich machen weil ich nicht die zeit habe mir jetzt eine analyse dafür zu schreiben und natürlich fertig super eine sinnvolle,
möglichkeiten zu haben und am liebsten halten sauberen gesetzlichen rahmen dafür.
Ja immer das gibt ja auch den mal wieder so zentrale ansatz versus die zentrale ansatz und sammelt ja auch eine menge gesundheitsdaten die bleiben aber sozusagen auf deinem device beziehungsweise.
Handy.
Werden auch wieder handy uhr genau.
Also ich habe jetzt eine neue und ich erkannt von der die daten von der alten uhr sehen also ich vermute die sind in der cloud aber.
Wollte ich auch gerade noch anfügen und sie sind auch verschlüsselt in der cloud aber sie werden halt nicht zentral bei apple in gespeichert.
Und dann gibt es halt entsprechende,
standards die sicherlich in den usa schon teilweise zum einsatz kommen habe ich natürlich wenig einblick aber für so forschungs- programme et cetera kann man sich ja zum beispiel auch anmelden dass man da anonymisiert solidarisiert dran teilnimmt,
und genauso würde ich mir das natürlich auch wünschen dass wenn ich jetzt zum arzt gehe und sagt der arzt na ja wir sind so aus mit ihrem puls und so weißt du ja kein problem ich hab da mal fünf jahre,
puls verlauf kann ich die mal in eben mal zugänglich machen so,
und damit wäre natürlich schon mal eine ganze menge geholfen das ist natürlich jetzt noch nicht gleich dieser durch analysierten daten pool wo alle möglichen sachen kombiniert werden aber,
zunächst einmal geht ja nur um meine daten ich will mich ja nicht mit anderen personen die daten mischen sondern es geht ja nicht nur um meine.
Du willst du willst einfach ein audi zitiert und revisionen fähigen beweis eines lückenlose puls verlauf der letzten fünf jahre auf not erbringen können ja.
Jetzt ist es sowieso mit unserer nerd perspektive,
mit so ich bin noch in der lage meine daten auch selber zu speichern und auf bedarf herauszugehen an wen ich möchte das funktioniert natürlich jetzt für viele leute und wird auch auf absehbare zeit für viele leute so nicht funktionieren.
Nein natürlich nicht.
Trotz alledem wäre natürlich ein konzept wie zentrale verschlüsselte speicherung wo ich dann bei bedarf von diesem zentralen stories zugriff
für einzelne ärzte freigeben kann oder eben auch für solche untersuchung ganz anderer ansatz der aber wenn ich das richtig sehe hier so nicht verfolgt wird.
Ja genau das denke ich ist auch der kern also das ist das kernproblem wir sehen ja durchaus
also es gibt ja innere unterschiedliche möglichkeiten auch daten freizugeben am ende sind das alles daten felder in irgendwelchen aktuell oder neues geld oder sonst was tabellen und man kann da irgendwie
die klassischen rechte konzepte drauf übertragen lesen schreiben,
gar nicht gucken und,
die komplexität irgendwie in eine yuri zu gießen,
wird halt auch die herausforderung sein grundsätzlich geht es aber das ist überhaupt ein das ist eine abbildung gäbe dass man diese rechte.
Und wie man das irgendwie gewehrt dass das mal gemütlich es ist halt angegangen würde das glaube ich kann man nur über entsprechende.
Regelungen dass es halt gesetzlich verpflichtet wird und irgendwie standardisierte und vereinheitlicht und ja also die lernen halt aus ihren,
mit ob in oder ob du gut und wenn wir uns also ein beispiel ist ja der.
Der neue personalausweis der evp her so wo sie auch gesagt haben na ja hier kannst du anmachen kannst ausmachen.
Und dann irgendwann mit einer revision des gesetzes gesagt haben so freunde das jetzt an,
so das ist jetzt bei die folge an ihr werdet nicht mehr gefragt ob ihr das wollt ja um um irgendwie weil sie festgestellt haben dass alle diesen personalausweis geholt haben weil es halt ne wollen wir nicht verkauft nichts an der tür so na und das.
Da wollen sie wahrscheinlich hier bei dieser medizin daten dass sie sicher sagen komm lass sie sich einmal aufregen wir nehmen die ganzen daten jetzt für peitschen das einmal durch und dann haben wir
die daten bevor wir jetzt uns hier die nächsten zwanzig jahre damit auseinandersetzen irgendwelche rentner zu animieren dass sie ein häkchen in irgend 'ner app machen so ne also,
man kann schon verstehen warum sie so vorgehen.
Ja ein großes problem wird auch bleiben einfach die infrastruktur bei ärzten selber die,
wir haben nun wirklich 'ne menge kosten zu tragen ich glaube diese wahrnehmung von über bezahlten ärzten das kann man gleich mal streichen der der der investitions druck de der so in praxen existiert für alles mögliche geräte ist eh schon hoch und,
die ganze computer drei macht's halt einfach nochmal extra
teuer da muss dann auf jeden fall auch unterstützung gewährleistet werden es halt zuverlässige und sichere systeme auch limitiert werden können weil die wollen sich dann nicht selber auf dem markt umschauen und so weiter so muss man,
einen ansatz fahren wenn man.
Gleichzeitig sind gleichzeitig sind die ärzte aber thema telematik auch total unglücklich dass jetzt zum kauf bestimmter systeme verpflichtet werden die müssen ja bluten mit irgendwie strafzahlungen wenn sie nicht an der telematik mitmachen und so sagen sie halt,
schwarze kiste kenne ich nicht kommt in mein haus ich äh gehe meine patientendaten darüber wer ist da schuld und sowas ne also da gibt's auch wieder viele viele sichten,
ich denke deswegen wird dieses thema halt gerade auch öffentlich diskutiert und deswegen setzt man sich ja seid,
zwischen einem jahrzehnt damit auseinander das funktioniert das system ja halbwegs auch
solange.
Müsste man den wahrscheinlich einfach mal stellen fertig.
Ja so damit wären wir bei unserem ersten thema und das ist ein themen wunsch der uns erreichte.
Julia und ihr wisst ja wir wollen gefallen wir wollen überzeugen wir wollen eure likes wir wollen eure klicks hinterlasst durch ein ständchen hinterlässt uns ein sternchen bei itunes und.
Abonniert spendet schreibt über uns.
Genau schreib artikel ihr wisst wir wollen gefallen deswegen euer wunsch ist uns befehlen.
Und zwar hat julia geschrieben hier hör mal was da los bei euch in berlin ich sehe mit dem flughafen ich nichts zu tun ne der genau das berliner.
Giga factory mann giga factory.
Machen wir jetzt ja.
Das jetzt wahrscheinlich schneller fertig als.
Wahrscheinlich der der milon muskat ja noch nicht gesagt wo er die hinbauen wahrscheinlich auf die stadt landebahn vom ber ja echt ich.
Doch ist schon klar wo bei erkner grün.
Ja ich habe es stimmt ja ich habe heute noch aber nicht die genaue fläche ist nicht klar aber die meinten im deutschlandfunk das ist wahrscheinlich irgendwie ein eine fläche ist die bmw auch schon mal haben wollt klar bmw
absteigenden ast da wird jetzt viel frei ne und das kann man natürlich die rosinen picken okay
so jetzt passiert folgendes,
berliner kammergericht sagt lecker funny it kaputt.
Wir brauchen jetzt eine zeit bis wir das wieder in griff kriegen,
und kommt damit in die zeitung außerdem in der zeitung die humboldt universität die sagt bei uns ist auch irgendwie wir müssen mal gucken bitte klicken sie nicht auf e-mails so.
Jetzt schon gesagt was das thema sein soll.
Genau ne da komme ich jetzt drauf was was ist es.
Emoji und ich weiß ich weiß es tatsächlich würde es ja eher emoji aussprechen aber viele deutsche sprechen ist ein hotel aus als ich bei mutter muss ich immer so ein.
Mopeds denken.
Ne ich muss an so ein emu denken weißt du so ein,
lange haarigen schwarzen mit mit irgendwie rendern unter den augen.
Sozusagen.
Gibt es dennoch ja ne die gab 's früher auf.
Demos wird's immer geben die zeit passen da immer noch ganz gut so.
Ich weiß nicht also da muss sind glaube ich noch depressive graffitis oder.
Auf jeden fall emotional sehr angeber also pass auf was.
Pass auf was du sagst.
Sorry.
Wir fügen wir fügen ja einfach alle träger warnung ein die das internet derzeit sofort.
Ja macht auf jeden fall auch ernstzunehmende ernstzunehmende emotionale verstimmungen lohnt das löst im hotel aus.
Was ist das.
Es handelt sich um eine sogenannte und ich glaube wir haben über e-motor ist ich sag jetzt im hotel,
heute sage ich eben guten morgen sag ich wieder emotion beim kunden sag ich immer.
Ihr system wurde emotionalisieren.
Okay wir lassen okay emoji eine sogenannte.
Das konzept einer ist ich werde das jetzt gleich ein bisschen ausführlicher erklären aber sie verschlüsselt die,
existierenden nutzerdaten auf dem computer und bietet dann einen schlüssel ein kiel zum entschlüsseln dieser daten.
Zum kauf an und das macht eigentlich in der it in den unternehmen und den bei den privatpersonen macht diese art schadsoftware seid ich würde sagen ich glaube es war zwanzig fünfzehn oder so.
Kopfschmerzen und ich wollte wenn ich wenn ich mit dem gewicht darüber mal erzählen soll dann habe ich mir gedacht erzähle ich mal so wie sich diese sache entwickelt hat warum das so ein,
lohnenswerten es vorgehen ist und komme dann irgendwann zu e-mobilität.
Und dem berliner dem berliner problemen.
Ich glaube wir werden erstmalig wenn's um wer in der schönen folge rentabel sicherheit aufgegriffen von zwanzig februar zwanzig sechzehn da kam das so ein bisschen auf da gab's schon mal so ein block aber jetzt fassen wir sozusagen mal zusammen was so der stand der dinge ist.
Ich glaube februar zwanzig sechzehn war auch die oder irgendwo in dieser zeit muss die sendung gewesen sein wo thorsten und ich lucky auseinander genommen haben für quarks und,
kaspar.
Wenn ich mich nicht täusche.
Es kann gut sein dass es da verlinkt ist verlinken wir aber auch nochmal da haben wir damals eine analyse des der,
massiv verbreitete okay also was müssen wir uns merken stand also idee dieser schadstoff er ist immer sie nimmt die dateien,
und zwar nur die nutz dateien die nutzer datei nicht die system daten in der regel,
die system daten verschlüsselt die alle und sagt dann hier die sind jetzt verschlüsselt die sind weg ich geb dir aber den schlüssel den du dafür brauchst um sie zu entschlüsseln gegen eine geringfügige bearbeitung gebühr.
Ok wir fangen wir jetzt an so ich fang jetzt an mit lucky das war so die erste generation von,
nehme ich jetzt mal bei der ersten generation und,
wenn ich über so wenn ich über schadsoftware oder angriffe spreche gibt es im prinzip immer so 'ne teilung die impliziert dem zu grunde liegt es gibt als allererstes einmal eine schwachstelle die schwachstelle ist
da sie es gut oder schlecht und sie hat
sie ist bekannt oder unbekannt sie ist einfach erstmal nur eine schwachstelle und als solche weder gut noch böse.
Erst wenn die schwachstelle ausgenutzt wird also das verwenden das anwenden dieser schwachstelle dann wird sie
explodierte das ist dann das ausnutzen der schwachstelle aber um durch das ausnutzen dieser schwachstelle bekomme ich als angreifer eben
unterschiedliche freiheit gerade auf dem,
zielsystem ja manchmal vielleicht eine komplette code ausführung manchmal auch nur das lesen bestimmter daten bei einer sql action oder oder oder aber quasi das
ausnutzen der schwachstelle ist der explodiert.
Und mit diesem explodiert gewinne ich dann quasi freiheit gerade auf dem zielsystem und was ich damit mache,
das ist die payton ja also zugriff bekommen und dann was ich überhaupt tue das ist die pay lotte und ist in dieser,
angriff kette immer eine p a lot nämlich das was ein angreifer mit dem system macht nachdem er oder sie eine.
Und dann gibt's noch einen,
potenziellen vierten schritt das ist die infektion und infektion bezeichnet das,
so dass wenn jetzt die schwachstelle entfernt wird oder das system neu gestartet wird,
dauerhaften zugriff habe klassisch würde man also sagen irgendeine form von trojaner irgendetwas was
a neu aufgerufen wird bei einem boot des systems.
B weiterhin funktioniert auch für die initialen schwachstelle weg ist und eben den,
sinn hat dass mir der zugriff auf das system dauerhaft.
Gegeben wird infektion ist nicht immer möglich und auch nicht immer nötig und infektion ist vor allem der teil,
auf den viren scanner sehr,
gut ansprechen weil es für diese möglichkeit sich dauerhaft in den system einzeln leisten zwar sehr viele,
aber immer noch eine endliche anzahl möglichkeiten gibt und deswegen sagen schadstoffe scanner zum beispiel oder schatz so fair systeme zum beispiel etwas wie,
lalala versucht software zu installieren darf da da,
und dann sagt man ja oder nein wenn man gerade nicht beabsichtigt eine software zu installieren dann sollte man im zweifelsfall aussagen möchte ich eigentlich nicht ja und,
das heißt dieser dass erlangen von per system ganz also das infizieren ist ein,
ein schritt der große risiken birgt erkannt zu werden ja man braucht
in der regel administration rechte dafür man hat die unter potenziell diese viren scanner die aufpassen und touristische touristisch allein schon diesen schritt erkennen das heißt dieser teil der infektion ist so ein bisschen etwas wo man sagt,
das ist auf jeden fall ein auffälliger schritt der unter umständen vom system erkannt und unterbunden wird oder von der nutzerinnen und.
Das interessante an der ersten generation war dass sie deshalb so erfolgreich war oder unter anderem deshalb so erfolgreich war weil sie auf diesen schritt verzichtet hat.
Systeme sind in der regel so getrennt dass die nutzer bestimmte,
haben lese schreibe zugriffsrechte und für bestimmte andere rechte eben administration rechte brauchen also ihr könnt mit euren eigenen dateien arbeiten die beschreiben löschen und so weiter aber wenn ihr software installieren wollt braucht ihr administrator unrecht oder müsst ihr ein passwort eingeben nochmal
aber der zugriff auf eure eigene dateien ist eine vollkommen unverdient wichtige tätigkeit,
und wer macht nur das sie geht nämlich hin.
Schreibt auf euren dateien rum was zu dem zeitpunkt eine vollkommen unverdient wichtige aktion für eine,
bekannte oder unbekannte software war,
und deswegen waren also diese erste generation hat also quasi einfach nur alle dateien umgeschrieben damit,
zunächst als sie aufkam die viren scanner offen falschen fuß erwischt,
die quasi keine holistic dafür hatten das kam dann später da komme ich auch gleich zu,
ok jetzt habe ich gesagt die also immer die payton jetzt gibt's noch die beiden stufen davor reality und explodiert also man braucht immer noch eine schwachstelle
die ausgenutzt werden kann und da arbeitet von der ersten bis zur aktuellen generation,
eigentlich immer mit sehr einfachen methoden und das ist der diese teilt also die schwachstelle und der experte,
der experte der schwachstelle die zum übertragen der pilot führen das nennt man drop.
Also ein der weg die schadstoffe irgendwie im in das system reinzubekommen die klassiker klassischem wege die sie nutzen sind so office dokumente mit einem mit einem skript drin.
Marko oder noch einfacher dateien die sowas haben wir eine änderung wie punkt pdf punkt exe,
und dass das also es ist eine ausführt bare datei und diese ausfahrbaren datei hat aber quasi nochmal ein also hat das logo von einem pdf sodass sie jetzt so aussieht wie,
gut kann ich aufmachen dann kommt der kommt der dobby.
Also hier zunächst einmal rein menschliche schwachstellen die zur anwendung kommen.
Beziehungsweise natürlich auch einen fehler des betriebs systems das öffnen von dokumenten und das staaten von programm,
für den user dasselbe ist.
Richtig ja da kommst du auf einen wichtigen punkt zu
ich wo ich mich freue dass das content team security meine einreichung zum sechsunddreißig drei angenommen hat wo ich nämlich über diese menschlichen schwachstellen einen kleinen vortrag.
Wollt ihr noch kostenlos reinkommen.
Ich habe schon ticket wie immer ein ein linus zeit sein ticket.
Ja ich auch.
Okay ich weiß okay.
Mehrere fehler windows zum beispiel zeigt die letzte datei änderung nicht an in bestimmten versionen empfindet das als komfort features und so weiter und so fort.
Jetzt also die beiden wege ich schick dir per e-mail eine,
eine solche datei mit irgendeiner cover story damit du die öffnest bei loki waren das gerne rechnungen ja rechnungen geschickt hallo hier öffne mal die rechnung im anhang wenn du draufklickst geht ein,
geht ein wort auf sagt witze das marco ausführen du klickst ja weil du immer ja klicks und fertig.
Das ist der einzige moment wo echte progressive ihre natürlich geschützt sind also sowas natürlich nicht öffnen würden.
Stimmt so ein bisschen andererseits ich meine diese fehlermeldung sind so
geknackt dass das die meisten leute halt einfach auf ja und bitte und weiter klicken da spielt gleich nochmal eine rolle wenn wir zu dem kammergericht,
kommen denn das kara gericht hatte seine workflow in einem auf office fünfundneunzig basierend den marco system
abgebildet das heißt die mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter des kammergericht wussten wort öffnen geht word öffnen und die warnung wegklicken
was sich nachher halt oft bei der emoji infektion als fatales problem erwiesen hat.
Ja bocke,
also dass die beiden wege und all das führt am ende dazu dass du dass du jetzt also ziel ist immer das am ende einer excel-datei nachgelassen wird oder dir schon gesendet wurde.
Damit du sie ausführst habe ich gerade gesagt in einigen fällen wird sie nachgelassen ja auch das hat einen einfachen grund weil viele viren scanner unterbinden das,
empfang von excel dateien ja wenn du aber eine partei kann kein e-mail-server ablehnen weil alle wissen dann
kommt das globale wirtschaftssystem zum stehen und deswegen werden halt markus in diese word-dokumente gesetzt die dann eine excel-datei nachladen und ausführen.
So was macht die excel-datei genau das was ich gerade beschrieben hat sie verschlüsselt alle dateien.
Zunächst einmal müssen wir aber noch kurz überlegen wenn ich als angreifer nun entscheidet diese methode zu wählen dann hab ich die wahl zwischen
mit einem gezielten angriff ja ich mach die fertig und schickt die nur an den tim,
einen massenanfall griff wo ich sage ok ich habe das ich habe diesen ganzen kram fertig und ich schick das jetzt mal
massenhaft an ein paar zehn oder paar hunderttausend leute und guck mal bei wem ich erfolg habe.
Erster verbreitung weg also hier erstmal nur e-mail und die erste generation hat danach auch wirklich einfach nur was ganz simples getan denn.
Sie hat als allererstes sich bei ihrem command in control server gemeldet und hat gesagt,
hier wir müssen einen neuen kunden anlegen und der kommandant control server hat daraufhin geantwortet mit einem,
also mit dem verschlüsselung objekt was die danach nutzt damit sie dann die dateien verschlüsselt so,
die der grund warum die rente wer sich erst in kiel holt ist das ja dieser computer auf dem sie jetzt gleich wirkt danach verbrannte erde ist.
Und das geschäftsmodell der angreifer ist diesen kiez zu verkaufen das heißt der erste schritt muss sein dass die rente sicherstellt den kiel der hier benutzt wird der ist auch,
an der haupt geschäftsstelle gemeldet und er kann dort in den handel gehen ja.
Das wort gründe in dem zusammenhang ist wirklich schön.
Die behandeln ihre leute als kunde.
Ja da kannst du auch produkten produktion.
So und justin time kriegst du dann von deinem kommenden kontrolle über einen kiel.
So der kiel der diese excel-datei holt sich also jetzt ihren kio und handelt irgendwie.
Oder sie würfelt sich selber ein kiel und meldet den beim kommenden control server je nachdem ob die symmetrische oder asymmetrische,
verwenden das geht aber wahrscheinlich für einige
der hörer zu weit deswegen machen wir es jetzt mal simpel sie stellt sicher dass an der haupt geschäftsstelle der kunde bekannt ist und der keep.
Bekannt ist so jetzt geht sie weiß sie sie hat alles was sie braucht und geht einmal durch den.
Durch den director also durch alle ordner und sucht nach dateien bestimmter änderungen das sind in meistens solisten von irgendwie hundert zweihundert einsendungen doktor stein excel dateien bilder und so weiter,
und verschlüsselt alle diese dateien mit diesem kiel
in der regel wird dann auch noch der name der datei geändert nämlich auf den auf die kundennummer was wenn asymmetrische gruppe zum einsatz kommt zum beispiel eben der die kiki einfach nur ist.
Und wenn sie damit fertig ist sagt sie übrigens,
die dateien die du suchst ne die sind verschlüsselt dann kommt immer der hinweis,
ja die kann man nicht irgendwie entschlüsseln sondern die sind jetzt wirklich verschlüsselt die idee von verschlüsselung ist dass es verschlüsselt ist und nicht vielleicht doch irgendwie entschlüsselt werden kann aber,
wir haben den key den du brauchst und den bieten wir dir.
Gegen eine geringfügige bearbeitung gebühr zum kauf an und dazu gehst du bitte auf folgende website das ist dann in der regel so ein tor hinten service und dort,
wird das,
das auftrags gewesen sehr automatisiert gemacht und zwar sagen sie dir bis jetzt also quasi in der phase du hast jetzt die e-mail angeklickt das ding ist einmal durch dein detail system rasiert und du gehst jetzt auf diesem tor hinten service.
Preisfrage warum kommt jetzt ein tor hin service zum einsatz vorher nicht weil um auf tor zuzugreifen,
musst du unter umständen,
wenn jetzt in einem unternehmens netz bist hast du unter umständen firewall regeln die das verhindern und irgendwelche orte im internet zum nachladen der schadsoftware oder zum
aushandeln von ein paar kies das kann man lieber über pn standard protokolle machen,
weil die server wo die sich die kies abholen oder wo sie,
wo sie die schadsoftware nachladen das sind in der regel einfach irgendwelche gehängten systeme und da haben die angreifer nichts wenn sie klug sind nichts drauf was ihn,
dauerhaft,
probleme bereitet das heißt da können sie gut damit leben sich jeden tag einfach woanders zu positionieren bei loki war das zum beispiel sogar.
Der hatte ein algorithmus für das generieren von domain namen und,
hat sich quasi jeden tag eine neue liste an domains gewürfelt wo er,
schauen würde wo jetzt quasi diese key aus handlung macht
den vorteil dass die angreifer wenn ihnen ihre domains beschlagnahmt werden,
oder wenn ihre domains gelöscht werden und ihre server und so weiter konnten sie immer sie wussten halt der algorithmus würfelt folgende,
domänen haben wir brauchen nur einen dieser vielen tausend liter pro tag generiert irgendwo zu registrieren und irgendwohin zeigen zu lassen um wieder die kommunikation
herzustellen all das über tor wer hätte halt viel mehr probleme,
deswegen machen sie das noch übers normalen internet jetzt das in kassel machen sie über einen hin service wenn du da drauf gehst sieht also folgendermaßen aus ist eine website sagt schönen guten tag.
Willkommen beim kundenservice du möchtest einen entschlüsseln für deine daten kaufen der kostet ich rede jetzt noch von der ersten generation lucky er war das verhältnismäßig günstig weil so fünfhundert euro.
Und dann dann dazu geben sie dir ein bitcoin wallet an und sagen da rein da in dieses bitcoin wallet müssen null komma hast du nicht gesehen bitcoin.
Und dann zeigen wir dir hier den kiez an den du brauchst um deine dateien zu entschlüsseln was ist daran so elegant die nehmen einfach für jeden kunden ein neues bitcoin wallet.
Und dadurch dass jeder kunde sein eigenes bitcoin wallet bekommt.
Können sie im prinzip automatisiert in der blockchain gucken ob dieses bitcoin wallet die entsprechende deckung hat und wenn es die entsprechende deckung hat dann geben sie halt den kiel frei,
ja das schöne ist kannst du da kannst du bauen vollautomatisiert und hat damit nichts nichts mehr an der backe,
das einzige womit die da noch was an der backe haben ist den leuten zu helfen,
irgendwie ihnen zu erklären wo man bitcoin kauft ja,
das heißt die haben über diese webseiten häufig auch noch irgendwie so chats oder so wo sie einem helfen,
außerdem haben sie auf diesen hidden service in der regel eine funktion.
Die crypt heißt wo du eine datei hochladen kannst und sie entschlüsseln dir die datei das ist um zu beweisen,
dass sie in der lage sind die dateien zu entschlüsseln ja damit du du weißt ja hier du behandelst du du kriegst nachher keine,
umsatzsteuer vorzug sap fege rechnung na das wir sind hier im bargeld
basierten gewerbe das wirst du schwer absetzen können und du kriegst auch keine garantie das heißt das bgb ist in diesem fall schwer zu informieren ja und,
allenfalls immer strafrecht könntest du den kommt genau deswegen haben sie auch einen service,
das heißt sie sie stellen die jeder andere ehrbare kaufmann erstmal unter beweis dass sie in der lage sind die angefragten dienstleistung auch zu deiner zufriedenstellend zu erbringen.
Also absetzen kann man die ausgabe später dann schon.
Aber nicht die.
Dein umsatzsteuer nicht aber wenn man das null vier bucht wäre das das konto sieben fünf fünf zwei verluste durch,
außergewöhnliche schadens fälle nur so als kleiner.
Mir war klar tim dass deine expertise auch bei diesem thema irgendwo noch rein.
Full service bei lok.
Ich wollte den ball spielen ja.
Aber das heißt auf das muss man auch nicht über drei jahre absetzen.
Nenne das kann man gleich.
Kannst du sofort schlägt sofort durch okay.
So jetzt fazit so lucky ist einmal durch die welt rasiert als massen angriff und hat im prinzip zwei.
Geschäfts mäßige fehler festgestellt das eine ist dass sie eine nicht,
optimale nicht risiko adäquate bepreisung vorgenommen haben da sie eine flatrate hatten ja also kommunismus und jeder konnte für fünfhundert euro oder fünf fünfhundert us-dollar seine.
Daten wiederherstellen das war das das eine problem haben sie natürlich festgestellt,
theoretisch wenn wir jetzt hier irgendwelche unternehmen treffen oder so da könnten wir vielleicht viel mehr nehmen als fünfhundert,
us-dollar und das andere problem was sie hatten ist der leute haben ein backup,
ja und da kann ich auch immer nur zu raten ich sag das ja auch oft genug kein backup kein mitleid,
sollte auch klar sein wer ein backup hat stellt seine dateien aus dem backup wieder her und ist glücklich
und vor allem bei loki ging das noch weil loki hat sich tatsächlich nicht das system infiziert der ist einmal durchgelaufen und war fertig.
Und deswegen brauchtest du zu dem zeitpunkt jetzt auch nicht irgendwie sagen okay ich musste computer neu aufsetzen oder susanne konntest wirklich sagen ne okay ich stell die dateien wieder her oder so und ich bin dann durch.
Diese probleme hat,
dann nach und nach die zweite generation,
angegangen und sie hat sich im prinzip zwei,
weitere funktionen dazu geholt die sag ich mal spezifisch auf geschäftskunden ab gezielt haben.
Die erste ist die versucht wenn sie jetzt quasi dein system befällt,
im lokalen netz weitere systeme zu finden und die zu befallen wenn es die möglichkeit gibt,
oder die bekanntesten beispiele sind hier das ganze mit der schwachstelle interne blut zu machen und da kommt dann so unschöne phänomene raus wie oder die beide,
die eigenschaft hatten dass sie jetzt nicht nur deinen computer befallen sondern im lokalen netz nach anderen geräten suchen diese unter umständen auch befallen können mit,
dem gleichen nutzer passwort oder über schwachstellen in freigabe oder sonstigen also.
Die schadsoftware wurde zum wurm einer schadsoftware die automatisiert versucht weitere systeme zu infizieren zweitens haben sie im prinzip so 'ne maßnahme eingebaut also zu sagen okay wir,
wir gucken mal was wir hier so.
Und gehen dann in eine individuelle bepreisung,
dass wir also sehen naja moment mal wir haben hier acht terabyte verschlüsselt auf zwanzig rechnern und es handelt sich dabei um ein um eine arztpraxis man
tim sagt für die ärzte sind arme gebäude wir wissen,
ganz fürchterlich so ein porsche ne was der frisst die haare vom kopf so ne das muss alles bezahlt werden und deswegen,
können sie dann eben überlegen ob sie jetzt zum beispiel bei den ärzten sagen okay da müssen wir gnade walten lassen wären es jetzt also es geht einfach darum.
Über bezahlten ärzte die im gegensatz zu den wirklich auf der straße lebenden security beratern.
Die kommen ja danach erst.
Haben sie gesagt okay wir machen jetzt hier individuelle bepreisung und optimieren unseren outcome.
Unseren return investment der investment ist ja relativ relativ gering,
das war so die zweite generation wo das quasi ein bisschen dazu kam und durch dieses herum marschieren haben sie natürlich auch gerne mal das eine oder andere backup erwischt aber immer noch dieses problem.
Backup insbesondere im geschäftskunden bereich blieb und dann kam quasi so ich meine diese generation,
diesen generations begriff benutze ich jetzt da kam so die dritte generation,
da werden wir jetzt beim guten alten e-motor.
Die dritte generation nach neumarkt.
Na die dritte neu manche generation im hotel ich meine ich habe da halt auch immer weiterentwickelt dran ne.
Immerhin bist du transparent.
Da wird der wird dieser weg umgedreht und zwar sagen sie wenn der wenn unser natürlicher feind das backup ist.
Dann sehen wir doch mal zu dass wir versuchen das backup auf jeden fall auch zu erwischen und im hotel ist spezifisch also spezialisiert er auf infrastrukturen und auf,
also auf unternehmen aus dem einfachen grund dass im geschäftskunden bereich eben auch einfach ganz andere prämien verlangt werden können.
So was macht was macht e-motor anders naja sie schicken dir ein drop aber immer noch genauso wie die erste generation eine excel-datei direkt oder eine word dokument wohnen wurden von marco drin ist.
Und wenn du das öffnest machen sie jetzt das was die erste generation nämlich genau nicht gemacht haben nämlich ein trojaner installieren.
Und bleiben erstmal auf dem rechner und kundschaft in den aus sie gehen in das e-mail-postfach und gucken holen sich da mal so die letzten weiß nicht wie viele hundert e-mails,
gucken da rein und spionieren erstmal aus um zu gucken mit wem haben wir es denn.
Und schicken diese daten erstmal zurück an den.
Commander control server wo dann die sachbearbeiter sich anschauen mit wem haben wir es denn hier zu tun.
Kundenberater ne also das was wir an deinem persönlichen persönlichen kundenberater der für dich ein maßgeschneidertes.
Geht.
Die gucken dann erstmal so aha ja mit wem kommunizierst du denn hier so ganz interessant,
verschiedene daten,
nach zum beispiel.
Ein passwort sammler ja da gibt es verschiedene free ways für aber das konzept ist immer das gleiche wenn ihr beispielsweise.
Ein programm verwendet wie,
für eure e-mails oder wie ein passwort speicher was weiß ich das jetzt in firefox oder im internet explorer ist auch egal in welchem browser der eingebaut ist.
Dann wird dieses passwort ja maskierte auf eurem rechner gespeichert aber.
Es gibt quasi ja den den ihr seht ja den zustand dass ihr den computer vom ausgeschaltet zustand in den eingeschalten zustand versetzt und der ohne weiteres in der lage ist dann eure e-mails abzuholen das heißt das passwort ist
zu greifbar auf diesen computer gespeichert,
und da gibt es eine reihe von möglichkeiten die sich dieses passwort eben wieder extra hier ja solange.
Also diese passwörter werden,
nicht im klartext auf die festplatte geschrieben aber solange ihr nicht den das verschlüsselte speichern aktiviert habt sind sie auch wieder zu greifbar.
Und da gibt es eben verschiedene möglichkeiten das wieder sichtbar zu machen letztendlich sind das extra akte aus den,
aus dem source code dieser systeme die einfach sagen alles klar ich bin jetzt mal nur der teil der sich das passwort wiederholt und holen sich so zum beispiel,
das e-mail passwort oder aber auch im browser oder sonst wo gespeicherte passwörter das ist der grund warum ich immer betone
dass ein passwort safe
auch mit einem passwort geschützt sein muss ja sonst habt ihr das problem in eurem firefox in eurem word und in anderen browser auch ich weiß dass einige betriebssystem und browser hersteller da jetzt zunehmend versuchen,
secure storage auf applikationen ebene hinzukriegen und so weiter und so fort das blende ich jetzt mal kurz aus
das ziel die angreifer haben sich also jetzt eure e-mail passwörter
und browser passwörter bemächtigen und haben im zweifelsfall jetzt schon mal ziemlich guten ziemlich gute einsicht in das was du da machst und sie können in deinem namen agieren zum beispiel e-mail schicken.
Sie machen außerdem natürlich
eine das sogenannte lateral movement was vorher ne zweite generation hat das noch automatisiert gemacht die gucken also jetzt mal so na wer gibt es denn hier netzwerk cheers was wird denn hier so gemacht gucken wir mal wen wir noch so
infizieren können wie viele informationen wir sammeln können alles halt noch auf leisen sohlen versuchen also jetzt
weitere systeme zu infizieren da gibt es ja tausend möglichkeiten wenn du einmal immer drin ist was was ich gibt's irgendwelche falsches wo du häufig genutzte dateien einfach mal nach infizieren kannst mit einem drop aber du hast ja jetzt relativ viel schreib zugriff oder,
wenn du sie nutzen dein existenten des e-mail-postfach um und hier,
wandelt sich das jetzt gerade die erste das erste verteilen des körpers ist häufig sogar massen mäßig.
Aber jetzt ist es wirklich ein gezieltes vorgehen deiner sachbearbeiterin,
irgendwo in diesem internet die sich darum kümmert.
Für dich das maßgeschneiderte paket zu machen und jetzt zum beispiel auf e-mails die du bekommen hast realistisch antwortet mit einem anhang an deinem chef zum beispiel hier danke ne datei habe ich gemacht,
ich bin fertig mit der arbeit chef guck mal fein.
Da ist er die künstliche intelligenz.
Da ist ein word dokument für dich ja.
Und jetzt sorgen sie dafür dass sie also möglichst viele geräte des unternehmens infizieren gehen dabei halbwegs planmäßig vor und halbwegs auf leisen sollen und verfolgen dabei eigentlich das ziel,
irgendwann einmal einen atmen zu erwischen at active try ist,
im prinzip so eine fernen wartung und richtlinien funktionalität von microsoft fern wartung ist der falsche begriff aber.
Telefonbuch würde ich sagen.
Telefonbuch und regeln also über active directly könntest du jetzt zum beispiel sagen du hast eine rechner flotte die ist an dieses active director angemeldet und das zum beispiel den
die möglichkeit zu sagen folgender nutzer wird jetzt ausgeschlossen dann kann er sich an keinem der rechner mehr anmelden du kannst zum beispiel auch dafür sorgen dass
dass jeder nutzer sich auf jedem gerät anmelden kann und dort seine umgebung wiederfindet du kannst aber auch zum beispiel regeln für die nutzer,
durchsetzen zum beispiel sagen pass mal auf alle nutzer hier kriegen folgende
wir müssen jetzt ein passwort von zwölf zeichen haben oder sonst was also es ist,
die möglichkeit wie du als gebäude windows atmen
mit keine ahnung paar hundert rechnern in der in dem unternehmen sicherstellt dass deine flotte da halbwegs einheitlich bleibt und du halt rechte verwalten kannst pflichten verwalten kannst sicherheits einstellungen verwalten kannst und so weiter.
Und wenn du das das passwort wenn du das passwort des adac advents hast dann ist game over das holen sie sich in der regel unter anwendung auch einer relativ simpel erhältlichen software unter dem namen trick bot.
Und trick pot,
im prinzip das ziel von trikot ist passwörter zu klauen die auf den geräten eingegeben werden und die warten also jetzt im prinzip darauf dass irgendwann einmal einatmen an irgendeine dieser rechner geht und dort sein passwort eingibt und das passiert,
leider sehr schnell denn wenn du als nutzer in deinem unternehmen saß.
Geht gar nix mehr was.
Computer computer druck nicht hallo i ja dann musst du ein und wieder ausschalten druckt immer noch nicht dann kommt jemand von der i vorbei und das letzte woche auf der bock hat ist mit deinen,
komplett aller zugriff oder rechte entzogen account hier irgendwelche scherze zu machen das heißt er meldet sich sofort an mit tim aus der it,
passwort dreiundzwanzig bonobos zweiundvierzig.
Mark mark.
Und und der trick pot sagt pass auf ich nehme ich und schickt nach hause.
Und jetzt sind jetzt hat das unternehmen leider das problem dass du eben,
dass sich die angreifer deiner deines ad gemächlich haben das heißt sie kennen jetzt auch alle unterschiedlichen rollen gruppen und im zweifelsfall sehen sie auch wo dein backup server steht.
Weil der den hast du ja auch ans ad angebunden weil wir binden alles ans afd an.
Ey alter ich weiß wo der backup sowas steht.
So
Jetzt gehen sie also hin und sagen alles klar als erstes machen wir unseren hauptfeind kaputt die backups und dann machen wir den rest kaputt.
Und laden jetzt eine nach also emoji oder im hotel ist gar keine,
selber gar keine nummer sondern erstmal nur ein trojaner der dazu genutzt wird die sagen wir mal die effizienz wirk macht und auch den die die überzeugung fähigkeit einer zu optimieren.
Und das ist dann schlecht dann sagen sie halt irgendwie ok pass auf wir verhandeln jetzt mal,
über einen preis und dieser preis ist dann bei emoji d ja das geht also das niedrigste was ich so gesehen habe war dann halt fünfstellig sechsstellig habe ich auch schon gesehen.
Und es geht natürlich auch in den inneren geht auch in den siebenstelligen bereich habe ich noch nicht gesehen.
Siebenstellige bitcoin bereich.
Das war nicht ganz.
So das was hast du also wenn dir so etwas passiert.
Hast du richtig richtig probleme weil was die unternehmen die davon betroffen sind berichten üblicherweise zwischen der infektion.
Und dem dass sie tatsächlich mal anfangen sich bei dir umzuschauen vergehen mehrere wochen und bis in die schadsoftware drauf tun vergehen auch nochmal eine zeit ja das heißt der typische.
Merkt unter umständen also wenn ich meine wenn die ganz aufmerksam sind da merken sie es zum zeitpunkt der infektion,
ja zu dem zeitpunkt haben die angreifer aber zum beispiel schon den einen zugriff auf 's immer postfach und haben schon irgendwie kenntnis von kommunikations vorgängen und so weiter das heißt jetzt ist es du denkst es ist noch nicht zu spät,
aber die haben im zweifelsfall schon so viele informationen und sich schon soweit soweit lateral bewegen können das ist.
Die gefahr nicht gebannt ist nur wenn du jetzt mal irgendwie ein passwort änderst und ein system desinfiziert die haben halt schon.
Passwörter als system administration.
Und wenn sie dann die zweite stelle wie das entdeckt ist halt wenn sie,
zum beispiel eben erst ein paar wochen später anfangen sich lateral zu bewegen bisschen auszu kundschaft,
auch da merken dann meinen dann viele okay krass wir haben jetzt wir haben sie jetzt raus ja wir haben alle passwörter geändert oder so.
Und stellen dann aber fest okay wieder zwei drei wochen später.
Ist auf einmal die drin und wütet einmal durch das system und die kommt bevorzugt freitag.
Ne weil sie dann wochenende zeit hat zu verschlüsseln ja also wirklich eine,
ein riesiges problem für die betroffenen weil die standard reaktion auf so etwas ist du du schaltest dein atem mehr oder weniger ab,
und baust auf der grünen wiese eine komplett neue it-infrastruktur,
komplett neuen passwörter komplett neuen nutzer konzepten.
So für die zinsen einspielen blablabla konfiguration dateien alles das dauert richtig lange,
und das ist teuer,
meine immerhin die chance beim nächsten mal auch richtig zu machen aber da muss man natürlich die lehren auch erstmal eingearbeitet haben und die zeit hat man dann meistens auch nicht unbedingt.
Das ist genau das problem und dann geht's halt zu kommen so frage.
Können wir nicht die rechte das rechte konzept von dem alten active try rüber ziehen in das neue ne und dann stellst du halt fest ja,
ich guck mal kurz kennen sie übrigens diesen menschen hier eine wer ist das denn ja das ist ihr atmen den sich die angreifer angelegt haben ja deswegen wer wahrscheinlich ungünstig wenn du jetzt umziehst und du hast halt neuen,
du ziehst halten bösartigen adi atmen mit rüber oder so also ein ganz also wirklich 'ne,
wirklich etwas was ein großes problem ist und wo du jetzt in der beseitigung der bekämpfung dieser infektionen.
Aufpassen muss wie ein schlosshund dass du dass du nicht hier irgendwo ein klitzekleines türchen offen hält dass deine nutzerinnen und nutzer nicht vielleicht sagen ach komm das alte passwort war eigentlich gut und mein sven sie nicht haben,
das war ja der kollege x y der hier betroffen war ich bin ja nicht so blöd und sodass du,
sehr schnell in diesem unternehmen sehr dramatische abwehr kämpfe.
Wir fallen jetzt mal so spontan aus meiner eher leinen haften betrachtung so zwei maßnahmen ein uns,
ein raum zu werfen kannst ja mal was zu sagen erstmal,
backup.
Die immer sozusagen live auf dem rechner rumliegen könnten natürlich dann auch angegriffen werden da würde sich sicherlich empfehlen sowas machen wie backups die.
Zum beispiel auf bänder gehen und die dann im regal verschwinden und die eben nicht online sind dass man darauf zumindest zugegriffen muss man ja nicht täglich machen aber zunächst einmal im monat also dass man so.
Würde ich maxim.
Je nach szenario,
und dieses administration slot in problemen man halt einerseits durch so passwörter,
also wenn du dich am,
rechner der user ein log sozusagen und nicht auf deinem besonders geschützten administration sc zentral bereich der vielleicht nochmal gesondert abgesichert sein könnte dass du dann sozusagen nur ein passwörter verwendest also nur einmal,
funktionieren wenn die infrastruktur das hergeben oder eben generell so ne zwei faktor authentisch wie wir das jetzt bei internet diensten haben auch intern zu verwenden also dass man an irgendeiner form nochmal so ein coaching retter aufm telefon hat den man noch zusätzlich eingeben muss.
Das sind gute möglichkeiten dummerweise wenn jetzt der nutzer also die sind ja im prinzip mit der rechten des angemeldeten nutzers meistens unterwegs weil sie das system infiziert haben ne sodass es,
letztendlich also kleine zwei faktoren,
verhindert unter umständen dass sie sich dann irgendwie mit den rechten die sie jetzt kennen,
nochmal irgendwo anders anmelden aber,
dann versuchen sie halt irgendwie an irgendwelche e-mails zu schicken also das ist wirklich wenn die sich da reinbeißen ist das richtig richtig scheiße,
und du musst wirklich davon ausgehen dass die sind gut beschäftigt,
die sind gut unterwegs und eigentlich ist deine einzige hoffnung.
Dass du das investment für sie zu teuer machst ja dass sie nämlich sagen okay ich nehme mir jetzt keine zeit mehr,
dieses angriffs ziel weiter zu verfolgen sondern ich arbeite an einem anderen fall wir haben ja genug.
Und das das ist ich mein im prinzip das was du machen musst zu dem backups würde ich noch mal sagen backup sind erschreckend billig
ich habe gerade wieder eine
acht terabyte festplatte für irgendwie hundertfünfzig euro gekauft die würde wahrscheinlich bei den meisten privatpersonen oder kleinen mittelständischen unternehmen vollständig ausreichen
für eine für ein backup aller betriebs relevanten
daten und mit hundertfünfzig euro oder was kannst du die einmal befüllen und in schrank legen,
ich hab ja hier schon häufiger von meiner eichhörnchen strategie des backups erzählt.
Dass ich nämlich die dinge auf voll verschlüsselten festplatten mache und diese festplatten,
auf diesen planeten verteile und sollte es mich irgendwann einmal erwischen
kann ich mir diese backups wiederholen finde ich wie ich jetzt grade sagte mit hundertfünfzig euro für so eine festplatte lächerlich billig.
Du kannst dir gleich ein abo klicken irgendwie christopher jede woche eine.
Der spaten.
Ja ja ja einfach so schick mir das geht auch ne schick mir einfach so einmal im monat einmal die woche schickt mir so eine platte gleich mit anschluss dran also im gehäuse.
Ja genau die die billigste kommt sogar in usb gehäuse also ich wollte eigentlich eine satte haben
die kommen aber in usb gehäuse der musste immer noch mal kurz mit dem hebel dran um die satter platte daraus zu rufen und das gehäuse wegwerfen ja so ist das ne,
ich weiß gar nicht noch weiter in backup konzepte in kriminelle backups und so weiter ich will nur sagen backup sind,
günstiger als jede forderung die es jemals gab
und dieses geld ist sehr gut angelegt und wer da nicht aufpasst und zum beispiel eben solche probleme hat wie das das backupsystem immer dran ist oder,
es kommt im unternehmens kontext auch so fragen hinzu wie wird dein backup gezogen oder geschoben also haben deine.
Die zu sichern denn systeme zugriffsrechte auf dem backup server,
oder hat der backup server zugriffsrechte auf den zu sichern den systemen wenn die zu sichern in systeme zugriffsrechte auf dem backup server haben sind sie unter umständen in der lage dort ihre eigenen backhaus zu löschen.
Das möchtest du nicht deswegen musst du eine musst du eine welt schaffen in der der backup server garantiert die backups bekommt,
und keines der anderen systeme sagen kann übrigens ich lösche mein backup und der backup service immer ich bin backup server ich lösche keine backups der eine job den ich habe ist keine backups zu löschen und.
Dann musst du eben mit diesen
mit dem emoji noch aufpassen dass der dich doch irgendwie als ad atmen auf deinen auf deinen backup server sagt und sagt hier einmal die idee wir machen ein backup von der fremde jetzt und
das wäre alles ist alles sehr ungünstig deswegen so ein ein gutes backup ist einfach nirgendwo angeschlossen du hast gerade schon gesagt kannst du auf,
sind erstaunlich teuer also bei der also die sind nicht so viel billiger als festplatten.
Dass es sich sofort lohnt in taps zu investieren,
also der der therapeut preis bei so einem tape ist immer noch hoch und du musst eine ganze menge tapes schreiben bis sie irgendwann billiger wird als festplatten.
Je nach szenario.
Aber jena szenario und so weiter wie du also unter umständen steckst du auch einfach an jeden rechner time maschinen oder zwei und wechselt die wie auch immer ja ich baue meine backups systeme.
Aber es ist lange her dass ich selber mal eins bauen musste weil das funktioniert ja jetzt aber als ich das auch noch für kunden gemacht habe gab es tatsächlich diese gibt's den,
sat a wechsels lot wo die platte drankommt und ein mitarbeiter hat den job jeden freitag.
Mit der anderen bäcker platte zur arbeit zu kommen die zu wechseln mit der bäcker platte an nach hause zu fahren so dass es immer ein ein wochen altes back abgibt,
hat eigentlich schon vielen leuten den allerwertesten gerettet problem ist wenn diese emotion,
leute das sehen ne und sieht es soweit ausgekontert haftet haben die können eine woche warten und dir das erste backups erschießen und dann das zweite insofern sind natürlich so einmal medien.
Wie tabs wo du halt einfach sagst okay rüber aus tape ins regal eigentlich planen für mein leben ist dass ich dieses tape nie wieder brauche
gar nicht so schlecht und wer da eben quasi versucht dauerhaft backup medien immer wieder neu einzuspielen geht eben,
ein geringes risiko ein was jetzt durch diese immunität leute immer größer wird insofern tatsächlich,
habe ich auch backups die einmal angefertigt wurden und die ich nicht beabsichtige nochmal zu überschreiben oder so da steht dann drauf.
Bis zweitausendachtzehn fertig.
Hilft euch das auch mal so als rand aspekt diese ganze absicherung gegen diesen feind von außen hilft wenn man jetzt ähnliche strategien anschlägt auch gegen den feind,
von innen
also so das angriff szenario durchgedreht der mitarbeiter der sich für was auch immer gerade mal rechnen möchte angemessener weise oder nicht angemessener weise auch da greifen natürlich solche dinge auch weil wenn er irgendwie,
was ich ein admin frei dreht und aus welchen emotionalen bedrohungssituation heraus auch immer beschließt ich mach jetzt hier mal alles platt
ja ist da sozusagen so 'ne physikalische trennung mit alten backups auch ganz hilfreich.
Also backup ist backup ist immer gut backup ist immer.
Und das ist eine lehre die jetzt sich langsam eins die langsam einzug erhält und leider bei privatpersonen immer noch am wenigsten ja ich hab gerade wieder.
Die diplomarbeit.
Ja genau.
Es ist immer die diplom.
Tatsächlich gerade wieder in gerade wieder im freundeskreis diplomarbeit da habe ich gesagt ja ich kann hier ein unternehmen mit sitz in vielen oder hamburg empfehlen die,
stell dir deine daten wieder her die haben aber auch einen preis und er sagt ja ich weiß das den preis haben ist völlig egal weil eben der schaden.
Mitunter unermesslich ist und das verhalten das war so ein klassischer head crash in ihren zum konsumenten laptop ne.
Also wenn ihr irgendetwas machen wollt,
macht und ich glaube jetzt so für den hausgebrauch gabs eine usb platte mit einem terabyte kostet glaube ich,
fünfzig euro oder sowas vierzig und mit zwei terabyte.
Ich einfach ein paar große.
Kaufen kaufen.
Kaufen kaufen kaufen.
Tim als was bucht man die ab büro bedarf einfach ne.
Ja kann man auch auch wenn sie teurer sind auch wenn sie über achthundert euro gehen kann man gleich voll absetzen weil es nicht eigenständig betreiben und von daher geht es immer gleich ins jahr.
Ne also ich glaub ich suche gleich mal ein paar platten raus machen wir ein paar schöne filiale links hier in unsere show notes.
Aber das heißt mein backup server weil der eigenständig betreiben fähig ist den muss ich über drei jahre absetzen.
Das kann man glaub ich dann auch noch.
Kann man nur drüber sein.
Immer eine frage der darstellung fähigkeit.
Also backup kein backup kein mitleid beziehungsweise ich habe schon mitleid.
Ein bisschen schon leider keine keine hilfe.
Ich helfe ja dann auch ist ja nicht so als würde ich nicht helfen.
Haben wir jetzt mal hier im vorfeld getan bevor es soweit ist und wenn es euch dann trotzdem passiert ist dann können wir zumindest rausreden kann sagen haben wir ja gleich gesagt ich sag nur.
Und ich sag noch ja da kommen wir mit dem nächsten thema direkt an einen punkt der.
Der anknüpfen und zwar gibt es hier eine gibt es in einem e-mails anbieter mit sitz in hamburg der den namen total notar trägt.
Und der hat eine anfrage achso hannover entschuldigung.
Es ist nicht alles in hamburg hannover meine arbeit schatz.
Sorry tim.
Meine ehemalige heimatstadt macht ja nix musste ich total dabei.
Die haben folgende funktionalität wenn da eine e-mail eingeht verschlüsseln sie diese eingehende e-mail pn wenn sie nicht eh schon p verschlüsselt ist.
Und damit speichern sie auf ihren.
Auf ihrem server quasi ausschließlich verschlüsselte e-mails die empfänger dann wieder entschlüsseln.
Wenn sie die lesen wenn du von einem account an den anderen schreibst ist sogar standardmäßig wird direkt ende zu ende verschlüsselt von dem einen account an den anderen
es gibt eine reihe von e-mail oder eine eine kleine auswahl an e-mail anbieter die das auch machen einer der mir einfällt ist proton.
Schöne idee und schützt eben vor,
irgendwie hacking des des e-mail post fass und das mit einer app zugriff oder sonstigen und vor staatlichen zugegriffen,
auf klartext so die haben eine anforderungen des amtsgericht bekommen und sollten,
bitte zu ermittlungs wecken gemäß fdp.
Die inhalte von e-mails sie unter einem bestimmten account eingingen zugänglich machen und die haben dann gesagt naja,
das können wir nicht weil wir keine kopie des klartext es erstellen der klartext kommt an wir verschlüsse den und das speichern wir und zweitens,
also wir können das nicht und wir wollen das auch nicht weil wir ein datenschützer ein datenschützer unternehmen sind und die e-mails unserer kunden sind für uns tabu.
Die haben jetzt eine gerichtliche eine gerichtliche verurteilung bekommen mit strafe geringe strafe von tausend euro aber,
die verpflichtung von
der preis gabe von daten zu ermittlungs trinken das heißt wenn also jetzt strafverfolgung zuhören bei total notar sich melden und damit im zweifelsfall auch bei
anderen e-mail anbietern und sagen hier uns ist das völlig egal du baust jetzt deinen prozess um dass du nämlich.
Dass du nämlich eingehende e-mails.
Wenn wir eine die eine anordnung geschickt haben auch im klartext ausführst also aus leitest.
Also mit anderen worten euer geschäftsmodell wird einfach äh hauptamtlich komplett ausgehebelt.
Ja mir fällt ein dass also ich.
Ja
ich sehe jetzt das post theo teilen der der.
Der artikel oder der berichterstattung widerspricht weil sie eine weil sie glauben dass die zitierten gesetze nicht stimmen.
Aber zumindest einmal das gesetz,
oder endlich das gesetz sondern das urteil was hier gefällt wurde ist jetzt erstmal da ich bin jetzt gespannt wie sich die,
wie sich total not a versuchen wir dagegen zu werden was sie jetzt tun,
das spannende ist warum hat das was mit zu tun ja weil hier die
verwendet die erpresser dieser als e-mail adresse eine e-mail adresse von total notar verwendet haben
und das ist natürlich jetzt mal aus sicht des e-mail anbieters ja scheiße ne wenn deine kunden kriminelle sind die damit andere erpressen,
eigentlich würdest du vielleicht gerne spontan sagen du bist nicht mein du darfst nicht mein kunde sein ich nehme dir die e-mail-adresse weg.
Das blöde ist die erpressung opfer müssen sich an diese e-mail-adresse melden das heißt du kannst jetzt wenn du sagst ne übrigens wir finden den erpresser genauso kacke wie ihr deswegen könnt ihr den jetzt nicht mehr erreichen ist halt auch keine handlungsoptionen,
also hier sehen wir ne mit diesen blöden sachen kommen dann eben wieder fälle die am ende,
blöde schäden für uns alle haben gerichtsurteile diskussionen über den zugriff auf auf e-mails und wir werden mal schauen.
Wie das wie das sich weiter verhält es ist natürlich ein also die haben natürlich.
Die strafverfolgung wollen er quasi einsehen so ungefähr wer da noch hin schreibt,
und was die für für forderung aufstellen um irgendwelche hinweise auf die täter zu bekommen total note hat natürlich argumentiert du pass mal auf die leute die hier hingeschrieben haben die haben.
Nicht ihre zustimmung erteilt ja dass sie da abgehört werden sondern die haben ja die sind ja in so einem fall aus irgendwelchen gründen nicht zu euch gekommen liebe polizei sondern lieber zu den erpresser.
Also ein ein spannend eine spannende rechtliche auseinandersetzungen.
Ich glaube lieber tim es ist zeit für unser für eine gute nachricht.
Die hat vor einem vor einem gericht in den usa jetzt muss ich überlegen was welcher ebene gericht ein fettes cord entspricht.
Na ja bundesgerichtshof.
Bundesgerichtshof genau bundeswehr klar ist eigentlich relativ einfach ein urteil erstreiten,
und zwar erinnert ihr euch sicherlich dass wir gesagt haben dass die usa ein gesetz,
verabschiedet haben oder quasi die praxis eingeführt haben an der grenze.
Die geräte zu kontrollieren und,
und zwar ohne genannten anfangsverdacht ja das nämlich also du kommst als bisschen ein reisender und du hast jetzt ein elektronisches gerät dabei und dann kommen die bundesagentur die dort also die,
eine reise machen die partner auf homeland security und sagen gib mal her wir gucken da jetzt rein wenn du sowas nein dann sagen die doch
entschuldigung ist es nicht dass die partnern es ist nicht dass die partner formeln security sondern die custom in bordeaux control und das migration carstens infos nennt also und eis die gegen illegale einwanderung und die
quasi sicherheitskontrollen die freundlichen herren und damen an an der einreise am flughafen,
dich dort fragen was du hier überhaupt wild und ob du versprichst dass du auch wieder gehst und dass du in kein psychopath bist und niemals den gedanken hattest den präsidenten zu ermorden.
Schließt das also die frage ist schließt das jetzt sozusagen nur die konkrete durchsuchung
der die weiß es vor ort ein oder deck das dann auch die praxis ab mit geben sie uns mal ihr twitter passwort wir wollen mal so ihre dms durchblättern bevor wir sie hier rein lassen.
Das hat er auch gemacht also hier der fall der klage war ein.
Ein mensch der quasi wieder eingereist ist in die usa und sagt sie haben meine,
anwalt kunden also meine anwalt klienten kommunikation durchsucht in boston am airport logan der hat quasi als ich dort eingeflogen bin mein mobiltelefon und mein laptop durchsucht und hat,
geguckt ob der ob im social media meiner freunde irgendwelche ansichten geäußert wurden die die us regierung kritisieren.
Und hat dann dem studenten den den zugang zum land untersagt.
Also die und die afd geklagt haben haben natürlich da auch wieder den spannendsten aller fälle gefunden ist ja.
So jetzt schon mal auf zwei null eins muss ich noch nicht mal für deine familie erklären sondern auch für deine losen freunde.
Ja und das geile ist also naja der typ den sie da.
Nicht reinlassen wollten den sie untersucht haben ist halt ich meine es boston ne da gibt es eine universität in der nähe.
Harvard wo der natürlich in erstsemester war also haben sie sich genau den richtigen ausgesucht der irgendwie voll privilegierten hoch intelligenten der irgendwie direkt mit den ganzen scheiß zu boden klagt und.
Das ist doch schon mal eine eine schöne eine gute nachricht ich bin mal gespannt über den bundesgerichtshof gibt's ja noch weitere aber das.
Ich meine so wie ich die,
die die konstitution der usa interpretiere kannst du eben auch nicht anlass los and sieges durchführen und das ist hier eben nicht der fall.
Na ja aber wir haben ja noch den von humanity da mal wer infizierten supreme cord in den usa der natürlich seine ganz eigene interpretation der verfassung derzeit implementiert da ist überhaupt nicht klar was da jetzt noch stehen bleibt
also.
Genau deswegen vielleicht müssen wir nachher das mit der guten nachricht nochmal rausschneiden wie wie donald trump hast du gesehen war donald trump hatte der hat.
Hier diese chance weißer der früher da für klauen geteilt,
für trump getanzt hat der tanzt jetzt in irgend einer fernsehsendung,
und ähm war da irgendwie im viertelfinale donald trump hat irgendwie seine unterstützung bietet man müsste den unterstützen und toller text
der typ wurde dann nicht hat nicht gewonnen wurde rausgewählt ja und dann hat donald trump sind tweet gelöscht,
weil er ja keine loser unterstützt.
Boah ist das niedrig,
ich mein gut immerhin hat er nicht sofort gesagt dass die die ganze blöde game show da diese tanzshow irgendwie geregt ist und
von clinton gekauft so insofern vielleicht ist das auch so der erste die erste wirkung der therapie aber das ist so niedrig naja.
Das na gut ich meine definiert jetzt schon seit längerem zeit die untere platte also von daher.
Ja weil ich mein was ist was ist null trump ja wo ist da der absolute nullpunkt so ich mein irgendwie jedes gala muss ein ende haben.
Sei es bei minus zweihundertdreiundsiebzig kevin oder was oder äh grad wo der null kevin ist auch immer irgendwas muss doch sein.
Ja also null null null kerl kevin ist die wärme die ich so empfinde.
Also von daher.
Wärme wärme spielt eine große rolle im sozialen netzwerk instagram.
Oh ja menschliche wärme.
Wie wir wissen ist das internet ja leider hauptsächlich inzwischen ein marketinginstrument und auf instagram gibt es nicht nur auf instagram aber auch auf instagram gibt es.
Sehr viele wie würde man das eigentlich nennen freiberufliche pro motoren sogenannte influencer die.
Ja dort sich ihre seele ruinieren im kampf um likes und das führt bei jungen menschen zu massiven,
emotionalen problemen und ich glaube es gibt auch wahrscheinlich nichts schlimmeres als eine bessere aussehende konkurrentin in deiner eigenen klasse zu haben die vier likes mehr
für ihr face bekommen hat da dass die menschen in schwere krisen stürzt testet instagram jetzt eine maß.
Tatsächlich wahrscheinlich gut heiße dass sie sagen ok wir zeigen.
Gesamte anzahl der erreichten likes eines posts nicht mehr der öffentlichkeit an,
du als diejenigen die die likes erhalten hat siehst das noch aber du stehst nicht mehr in einer öffentlich wahrnehmbar in konkurrenz.
Zwischen mit den anderen personen den du jetzt nach etwas oder mit denen du hast.
Das ist natürlich eine totale krise für die nacht gelagert 'ne halbe journalismus der da im social-media-bereich betrieben wird weil wir sollen die denn dann auch wissen was angesagt ist.
Das wird der instagram algorithmus ihnen schon vorne und hinten reinschieben da bin ich mir relativ sicher,
ich finde das auf jeden fall mal also ich bin mal gespannt wie dieser test verläuft es gibt natürlich verschiedene möglichkeiten das zu umgehen ich könnte mir vorstellen dass die leute dann jetzt alle immer die screenshots von.
Aus ihrer,
posten und sagen likes äh wie viel hast du mehr live aber es.
Lässt sich ja leicht faken.
Genau lässt sich leicht faken also ich bin mal gespannt also wir müssen glaube ich dieser sache in in die augen sehen dass diese social networks mit ihrer öffentlichkeit.
Mit ihrer veröffentlichung und gamification von anerkennung zustimmung und beliebtheit nicht unbedingt das beste in menschen,
hervorrufen und nicht unbedingt das das beste für die menschen sind und wenn hier versucht wird,
wieder experimentiert wird mit wegen das irgendwie einzudämmen finde ich das auf jeden fall mal ganz interessant.
Ob das das problem lösen wird nein aber vielleicht hilft's.
An der stelle nochmal die kultur referenz zu south park episode zero friends.
Ja eine.
Steckt schon eigentlich alles drin was man darüber wissen muss.
Dann hat die bundesnetzagentur ihre reise warnungen veröffentlicht wir erinnern uns die haben ja eine funkloch app gemacht.
Bitte dieses bundesland nicht einreisen.
Jetzt die karte heute wo wo du sehen kannst welche geschwindigkeit mit der,
mit der du dort erlangen konntest er und jetzt kannst du sehen welche welche bereiche von deutschland du möglichst meiden solltest.
Ja wobei sie ich habe mir diese app nicht nicht installiert und nicht nicht geguckt
wie das gut funktioniert aber ich fand diesen hinweis bei der partikel etwas fragwürdig so nach dem motto naja da wo jetzt sozusagen kein netz angezeigt wird das kann halt auch sagen dass er gar keine daten geliefert worden
weiß wieder nicht ob diese app nur so funktioniert hat dass ihr nur nur nur dann ergebnisse zurück liefert wenn sie überhaupt nichts hat,
anstatt das einfach mal äh zu speichern und dann wenn man nichts ist irgendwie raus zu kippen.
Arbeite ich muss.
Oder ob einfach nicht genug leute mitgemacht haben.
Also ich habe gerade diese karte aufgerufen ne und hier steht jetzt.
Hohe auslastung der karten darstellung aufgrund von hund zu sein auf die breitband messung garten der schule ist die nutzung des dieses zurzeit eingeschränkt wir bitten sie später zeitpunkt neu zu starten.
Oh
Deutschland deutschland.
Deutschland.
Ja aber immerhin kannst sie können sich ja freuen dass das ihre reise warnung sich hohe nachfrage.
Vielleicht ist das wirklich so der der neue der der denise globale germanys mus der sich so durchsetzen dass wenn du irgendwo im land kein netz hast dass er sagt ja ein arm in deutschland her.
Das ist deutschland hier heißt keine.
Ja wir werden da wir sind einfach der der dicke star im digital detox gewerbe ja das ist noch eine ganz große nummer.
Ja bei gesundheit kennen wir uns aus.
Führende führende führende expertinnen im digital detox ja deutschland.
Ja ja.
De
Ihr habt keine likes mehr bei uns kannst du überhaupt gar kein like vergeben.
Ah
Ach gott was sind wir dafür rand monster geworden aber es ist halt einfach wirklich schlimm egal weiter im text.
Ja ganz kurzer hinweis noch wir werden ja freundlich.
Einen termin oder was.
Ja so ein bisschen termin aber irgendwie nicht in,
das ist auch auch in dortmund und nordrhein-westfalen läuft gerade der coding da vinci
kultur hecke von da kann man sich jetzt schon und auf der in den shownotes verlinken seite anschauen was da so gebaut wird an projekten.
Es ist und ja also der kultur hecke von da geht's dann quasi um kultur daten,
die irgendwie zu interessanten anwendungen umzubauen da gibt's sachen die sich irgendwie mit,
bomben in moers auseinandersetzen mit schlagwörter daten aus dem kohle bergbau,
stadtarchivs live und ähnliches was dort an daten verarbeitet wird und,
am sechsten zwölften ist der achtwöchige kulturwerke von vorbei da findet dann eine preisverleihung im,
dortmunder u stadt und ihr könnt euch das dann anschauen.
Dann haben wir noch zwei jobangebote zu verteilen ja und zwar erstens,
suchen unsere freunde bei frag den staat eine juristin ab februar zwanzig zwanzig mit sechzig bis einhundert prozent und zwar geht es da um strategische klagen.
Und die stelle die es zu besetzen gilt ist die head of legal für frag den staat wir wissen ja seit einiger zeit das frag den staat,
gezielt auch auf das frei klagen von dokumenten sich konzentriert hat,
wir kennen die vorträge verklagt den staat
und nach frag den start kommt verklagt den staat würde waren ja auch die zusammenarbeit holen zusammenarbeit mit der
also wir sehen das frag den staat mit seinen kampagnen für informationsfreiheit ja immer mehr,
eine ausweitung und das einklagen der informations freiheitsrechte eintritt und dafür wird hier eine juristin,
gesucht.
Das dafür verklagen juristen die nicht unbedingt jetzt in dieser ausbeuter industrie unterwegs sein wollen doch eine schöne sache.
Ja ich kenne ein paar leute die ich da dich dahin schicken könnte was die was die was die dazu sagen also genau da gibt's einen job und,
der patrick breyer deren von der piraten partei im europäischen parlament tätig ist der sucht eine,
einen privatsphäre expertin in deutsch und englischer sprache
die dort als seine akkreditieren parlamentarischer ist a systems ganz in brüssel arbeiten soll da geht es dann in den
liebe und juri ausschuss mit fokus auf privatsphäre und internetfreiheit ein job in brüssel eigentlich,
nicht uninteressant mit patrick breyer hast du da dann einen,
chef oder ein arbeitgeber weiß nicht wieder wie dieses wie diese rolle dann heißt,
der ja auch wirklich seit weit über zehn jahren wenn ich das jetzt richtig sehe sich
im bereich der digitalen grund- und bürgerrechte und des datenschutzes hervor tut und hier im europäischen parlament
durchaus akzente setzen wird das ist eine nicht unwichtige rolle die ich fast.
Sag ich jetzt mal vorsichtig vergleichen würde mit so einer rolle wie die von ralf ben rad mit,
jan philipp albrecht und den hinweis habe ich auch von ralf ben rad der nämlich sagt in dieser position gibt es einen weiteren benefit und der ist dass man mit ralf ben hat relativ viel zu tun haben wird,
insofern.
Das nicht das schlimmste.
Das ist sicherlich nicht die schlechteste stelle die in brüssel angeboten wird.
So zeit des fortgeschrittenen sendung wird zu ende gebracht du musst los genau und insofern machen wir jetzt nicht mehr viele worte sondern sagen einfach äh tschüss bis nächste woche.
Tschüss und macht eure backups.
Oh ja zwei.